hello and thank you for joining us
for this agilent technologies cell
analysis webinar series
my name is ian hayes i am the farmer
market manager within the cell analysis
division at agilent
and i will be your host for today's
webinar
before i introduce our speaker for today
allow me to share a bit about agilent
technologies
and the products we offer for cell
analysis
agilent is a trusted leader in life
sciences clinical research
diagnostics and applied chemical markets
providing laboratories with instruments
services
consumables applications and expertise
to enable our customers to gain the
insights they seek
agilent's rapidly growing cell analysis
portfolio
enables deeper more realistic insight
across a variety of cell analysis
applications
where investigators and drug developers
seek to understand complex
cellular environments and interactions
this is critically important in the
large and growing
immuno-oncology and immunotherapy
indications
i'm delighted to introduce today's
speaker dr sandra malasta
senior scientist for elevate bio walls
of massachusetts
to present on the fascinating and
topical subjects
of metabolic regulation of adoptive
immune cell function
sandra received her phd from the
university of glasgow in the uk
and charts an impressive career from
academia into industry
with extensive research experience in t
and b
cell biology and a core focus on immune
metabolism
and mitochondrial function sandra spent
12 years at saint jude children's
research hospital in doug green's lab
before joining bluebird bio and then
most recently
elevate bio where she leads the
implementation of processes
and experimental platforms to develop
t-cell products
and supports the company's immunotherapy
programs
before i hand over the mic to sandra i
would like to remind you that this
webinar is interactive
and there will be a question and answer
period immediately following the talk
you will notice on your screen that you
can
and in fact should type in your
questions during the presentation
as this helps to ensure that we get as
many of your questions as possible
with that thank you sandra for joining
us today and please
take it away
thank you ian for this really kind
introduction and i'm really excited that
agilent gives me the opportunity
to talk a bit about my work on metabolic
regulation
of adopted immune cell function and the
wider implications
of those research efforts for cellular
therapy development
i just have to start with a quick
disclaimer that even though i'm not
working at
i'm obviously expressing use that on my
own and are not necessarily
shared by elevator
it is widely accepted now that t-cells
undergo metabolic reprogramming in
response to activation
naive t cells are considered to be
metabolically quietened with only basal
nutrient uptake to support their
maintenance
and they break down fatty acids glucose
or amino acids
to fuel oxidative phosphorylation
in response to activation t cells
undergo
metabolic reprogramming and now they
switch from oxidative phosphorylation
to aerobic glycolysis and this metabolic
reprogramming
is essential for them to supply enough
physical intermediates for the synthesis
of lipids
nucleic acids and proteins to support
this exponential growth
and proliferation as well as to maintain
the rate of balance of the cell
membrane t cells are now considered to
be metabolically primed
and similar to ac cells they again
rely on oxygen phosphorylation to gain
energy
but this is now mostly fueled by fatty
acid oxidation
they also have an increased spare
respiratory capacity
as well as mitochondria content and it's
the thought that those
features enable the t-cells to
devise long-term as well as to quickly
respond to secondary challenges
so to add another layer of complexity in
the virtual t-cell subsides
also has a unique metabolic phenotype
to support their specialized function
and maintenance
so for example th1 2 and 17 t-cells
drive energy bio glycolysis whereas
regulatory t
cells rely on oxidizes phosphorylation
fueled by fatty acid oxidation
this regulated immune responses are the
hallmark of many immune-mediated
diseases
including autoimmunity and allergies
where obviously
excessive immune responses have very
detrimental effects
on the other hand the generation of a
robust and
stable t cell response is the goal for
any vaccination strategy as well as in
immunotherapy
so therefore the idea that by targeting
metabolism
you can drive a desired t-cell phenotype
and thereby
improve current treatment strategies
for therapeutic or immunization diseases
is actually very appealing
in a healthy person the t cells
exist in an environment that is
provide sufficient oxygen as well as
nutrients that are essential for proper
diesel functions
including glucose glutamine and arginine
therefore enabling the generation
of robust effector response and
antivirus immunity upon encounter of the
virus
however in the tumor the t
cell encounters a very different
environment and especially in the solar
tumor
low oxygen concentrations lead to
hypoxia
and the t-cell now also has to compete
with the tumor cell itself for the
available resources and more often than
not unfortunately the t-cells move
out to the tumor cells and this now
drives sub-optimal effective responses
and often leading to t cell exhaustion
so i therefore became interested really
early on to understand if we can improve
the anti-tumor response by manipulating
the metabolic pathways in t-cells
so in an attempt to address this
question or answer this question
i'm going to ask the following questions
and answer them as well so what is the
function of ais and lymphocytes
why is aif essential for survival of t
cells but dispensable nd cells
what does the role of c make in driving
effector versus memory differentiation
of t cells
and finally thus targeting metabolism
influence-cut t-cell differentiation
as all of you know there's two main
pathways in the cells to produce energy
and there's glycolysis on oxygen
phosphorylation so
i'm just going to give a very brief
overview of those two processes
during glycolysis glucose is converted
to pyruvate which can have one or two
phase
it can be either converted to lactate
and excrete it
or to acetyl create which then fuels the
gpa cycle
the tca cycle has two main roles it
supplies substrates for synthesis like
citrate
but it also produces the reducing
equivalent
necessary to support oxidative
phosphorylation
so during oxidative phosphorylation
electrons are passed
from an electron donor to a more
electronegative
acceptor and oxygen is the final
electron acceptor which is then reduced
to water
and when electrons are passed between a
donor and an
acceptor free energy is released and
this free energy
is then utilized by complex 1 3 and 4 of
the respiratory chain
to pump protons across the inner
membrane
from the matrix to the intermembrane
space leading to the generation
of the mitochondrial membrane potential
and it's ultimately
the proton gradient that then drives atp
production
when those protons flow back to complex
paths
aif is a mitochondrially localized
protein
and it was initially described to be the
main mediator of caspase-independent
death
as it was observed that upon
promobilization of the outer
mitochondrial membrane
af translocates through the cytosol to
the nucleus
where it then reduces chromatin
condensation as well as large scale dna
fragmentation
actively leading to the depth of the
cell and therefore
it was also named aif for apoptosis
inducing factor
however very soon after its initial
discovery it was also observed that loss
of ars
leads to lots of expression of
respiratory chain complexes within the
mitochondria
which then in turn leads to defect in
respiration
and an increase in ros causing the
death of the cell due to metabolic
insufficiency
so i was therefore interested to
understand the role of ais
in lymphocytes is it actually an active
mediator of cell death
or is it important to maintain survival
of those cells
aif silly um af
is um embryonically lethal in
considerative knockout animals so i
therefore
cross a conditional air efflux animal
first through log stop log y p report
animal
and this allows me to track the cells
that has exist
successfully deleted a f by just
following the y t signal
and those animals are then crossed to
specific deletion animals where i then
deleted um the arf specifically but in
the d
cells by crossing a spider through the
cb19 cream out
or i crossed it to the lck cream out if
i wanted to delete ars
only within the detail image
to understand the role of ars within
mature t cells the first thing i did is
that i isolated the spleen
from wildlife or t-cell specific af
nogal animals
and what i observed is that loss of aif
leads to severe reduction
of those t cells within
the periphery and this effect is always
more pronounced on cd8 t
cells compared to cd4 t cells and that
is something i consistently see
solved throughout my study
and as has been described in the
literature before
loss of a f leads to reduced expression
of subunits of respiratory chain complex
one
three and four but not complex two and
five
and the most likely explanation for this
is the
complex one three and four form those
so-called super complexes and it's
thought that
loss of one part of the complex leads to
disintegration of the whole complex and
then to the degradation of all of its
components
and even though loss of ais reduces
the amount of respiratory chain
complexes within t
cells it does not affect the ability of
t cells to consume oxygen
under resting conditions however it
dramatically
impairs the ability of those t cells to
upgrade the lathe of the phosphorylation
and response to activation
i therefore wondered if one possible
explanation
for the fact that i see a lower
frequency
of t cells in response to deletion of
aif
is that they a lot of af
calls as an impaired homeostatic
expansion
so to test this i isolated t cells from
either a realtor
or t cell specific af not animal and i
then injected them at a one-to-one ratio
with congenital t-cells into a rectangle
and indeed loss of ars
impairs the ability of t-cells to
homeostatically expand
and again this effect is more
for cda t cells than for cd4 t cells
having established that aif plays an
essential role
in maintaining homeostatic expansion and
survival and t cells
i next wanted to investigate the role of
aif in my pure b
cells and because i want that it is
equally important
for the maintenance of those cell
populations so i therefore
again isolated spleens but this comes
from volatile or d cell specific af
knockout mml
but what i observed now is that lots of
af
does not affect the number of c cells
within the periphery
and there's also no selection against
the loss of
aif as i don't see a
selection against loss of white key
and just like what i observed in t cells
lots of af still leads to the
reduction of subunits of complex 1
3 and 4
but in contrast to t cells a lot of
ais does not impair the ability of b
cells to consume oxygen either under
resting conditions
or in response to activation and i have
to say
i was a bit surprised by those findings
because i have to admit i did not expect
to not see
any defects on b cell function
or survival if i see such a reduction
in expression of those respiratory chain
complexes so i thought okay if i just
use a stringent enough model
then i will be able to detect a defect
in those
um b cells that have deleted af so for
this
i infected my either volatile or c cell
specific
knockout mice the flu and then on day 10
i analyzed the number of
um antigen specific t
cells either within the mediastinal
lymph nodes or the spleen but even under
those conditions i could not detect any
defects within b
cells due to loss of ais
so this leads to the obvious next
question why is this ars
essential for survival of t-cells but
completely dispensable and detailed
there have been reports in the
literature describing that for t
cells to mature out of the thymus they
need to delete the mitochondrial content
via autopsy or decrease the mitochondria
content so therefore the idea is that
if they have reduced mitochondria to
start offers
suctivation will have more severe
effects on them
so to test this i isolated b and t
cells from a wild wild-card lexicts
animal and determined the amount of
mitochondria but in each of those
populations
however as is shown here those b-cells
and t-cells have comparable amounts of
mitochondria
so most likely that's not the
explanation
but since aif is a module congruently
localized protein i wonder if maybe
there's a
qualitative difference between the
mitochondria in
g and b cells so i therefore took
advantage of the cartionic dye to memory
so the uptake of this dye is directly
depending on the mitochondrial membrane
potential
so the higher the mitochondrial membrane
potential the more dye will be taken up
and indeed what i observe is that cda t
cells have the lowest mitochondrial
membrane potential
whereas wild type b cells have the
highest mitochondrial membrane potential
and this is obviously really interesting
because this is an inverse correlation
to the dependence on ais
to understand the role that this
mitochondrial membrane potential plays
within those two cell types i repeated
this experiment but this time in the
presence of oligomycin
so oligomythine is an inhibitor
of complex 5 and therefore prevents
the flow of protons back
from the inter membrane space to the
matrix so if the cell
now uses the octave phosphorylation
to generate energy that would mean that
complex 1 3 and 4 still pump protons
across
and that would lead to an increased
mitochondrial membrane potential
and this is indeed what are observed in
case of the t
cells so now um oligomycin
increases the mitochondrial membrane
potential to a similar level
observed for b cells whereas
oligomycin has no effect on the
mitochondrial membrane potential and
nasals
giving the idea that most likely b cells
rely
on glycolysis to generate energy
another way to test this idea is by
modulating the available carbon source
in the media
during glycolysis glucose is converted
to glucose 6-phosphate
which can then either be shuttled into
the pencil's phosphate
pathway to produce reducing equivalent
as well as nucleotides
or it can ultimately be converted to
acetoa
driving the tca cycle in this scenario
the t cell or the b cell can produce
atp by glycolysis as well as oxidative
phosphorylation
however if you now switch from
glucose to galactose the lactose is also
converted to glucose 6-phosphate
by the last pathway but this is a very
slow process
and therefore most if not all of the
glucose 6 phosphate
is no shuttle into the pencil's
phosphate pathway
and therefore the cell will not be able
to produce energy
via atf bioglycolysis however
oxidative phosphorylation can still go
on
as the tca cycle can be replenished
via glycoglutaminolysis
i therefore tested the ability of walter
b or t
cells to proliferate in other
depressants of glucose or galactose
and whereas t cells are still able
to proliferate in galaxies containing
media
even though it's at a slow rate b cells
are unable to do so again indicating
that they most likely rely on the
glycolysis to generate energy
and it's also therefore not surprising
to see
that since a lot of ars
impairs mitochondria function
lots of aif also impairs the ability
of t cells to proliferate in galaxies
containing media
as is shown here and again this effect
is
stronger for cdht cells
than for cd4 t cells
so consequently lots of af
leads to reduced atp generation
within the t cell population
but not within the beta population
so just to summarize this part of the
talk
what i've shown you is that in healthy
cells when aif
is expressed in the mitochondria b
cells rely on glycolysis as well as t
cells relying on oxidizer
phosphorylation
can generate the energy they need and
are therefore able to survive
however depletion of ais
leads to reduced expression of
respiratory chain complexes within the
mitochondria
so now these cells since they rely on
glycolysis
to generate energy are fine whereas t
cells are now
unable to meet the metabolic demand and
will therefore die
in the next part of this webinar i'm now
going to talk about
the role of c make and driving effector
versus memory differentiation and t
cells our lab
has previously shown that activation of
t
cells leads to an up regulation of c mic
protein within the first 24 hours
and it's this upregulation of c-max that
ultimately drives this metabolic
reprogramming
as deletion of milk leads to reduced
glycolysis
and as i've said in the introduction
this metabolic switch to aerobic
glycolysis
is essential to support exponential
growth and proliferation
and therefore loss of milk also impairs
the ability of t-cells to proliferate
having established that mick plays
an instrumental role in regulating
metabolic programs at the early stages
of activation we next wanted to
understand if mig is equally important
to maintain this metabolic program
once the cells have started to divide
to visualize mick in activated t-cells
we isolated t cells from c make gfc
fusion animals that also expressed the
ot1 transgene
we then in retroactivated those t cells
the cd3 to be 28 and gated
from the cd8 high and cdh low population
but in the first division a cd8 is a
marker for
asymmetry and observed that the cells
that express high levels of cd8
also express higher levels of cemex we
then confirm those results on the
personal basis
by confocal microscopy observing a
really nice correlation
between to the eight and semit
expression
and this indicates that c make just like
cdas
is isometrically distributed in
activated t-cells
those different levels of cmic also have
a significant impact on the metabolic
phenotype of the cell
after the first after division
as the scenic high cells have a higher
rate
of glycolysis compared to the semicolon
cells
and this higher rate of glycolysis also
drives
enhanced proliferation and glycemic high
cells
so this shows that the glycemic level
that's in the first division
directly affects subsequent
proliferation events in the t-cells
to now understand the functional
consequences
of the mig expression in people
we adoptively transfer steaming high
cells or low cells
from the first division into chromogenic
wild
animals and these animals we then
infected with flu
and analyze the immune response two
weeks later
or additionally we re-challenge
those my after four weeks with a
heteroseptic virus
to restrict the recall response
to the t-cell lineage only before
analyzing the flea and peripheral lymph
nodes
during the primary response we mainly
detected
the scenic high cells which is not so
surprising considering they have a
higher proliferative capacity
whereas we barely detected the
semi-gloss cells
however in response to wrist challenge
we observed the inverse pattern
now the cemic high cells were barely
detectable
indicating that even though they had a
robust effector function early on
that failed to differentiate into proper
memory
in contrast to this the cemic low
expressing cells
were able to persist and therefore could
respond to secondary
challenge so if our hypothesis
therefore is true that by that if you
make
by regulating metabolic programs
directly regulate the function of the
cell then we should be able
to affect the tissue phenotype by
modulating schemic levels
so to test this idea we adaptively
transfer
high or cd8 low cells isolated from
either a wild type
or a mick head animal which therefore
has reduced expression
of mig and
in that scenario the cd8
high cell isolators from a steemit head
animal responded equally well to
secondary challenge
compared to the cd8 low cells
from the head or the wall top animal
whereas
the cd8 high cells from the wild cup
animals
failed to do so
so based on this data and data i
unfortunately don't have
time to share with you today we propose
the following model
a strong activation stimulus for a t
cell
leads to increased surface expression of
amino acid transporters which then
enables the uptake of the amino acids
regarding entrepreneur activation and
cmic
expression which then in a positive
feedback loop
leads to enhanced further enhancement
of surface expression of those amino
acid transporters
driving the generation of t-cells with
an effector-like phenotype
on the other hand if the t-cell receives
a weaker activation stimulus
a lower amount of amino acid
transporters
will be expressed as the plasma membrane
therefore
less amino acids will be taken up
leading to
reduced and torque 1 activation or simic
expression
and this drives the generation of t
cells with a memory-like phenotype
because the t-cell memory effector
and differentiation is
regulated by metabolism-driven
processors
the approach that's the approach that by
manipulating metabolism
you can generate an
effective as well as sustained
anti-tumor response
is really appealing
whereas increased glycolysis leads to
the generation of effector t
cells it often also drives terminal
differentiation
on the other hand reduction or
of glycolysis or inhibition of
glycolysis
drives the generation of t cells with a
more memory-like phenotype that are able
to persist and therefore respond to
tumor relapses
so at this point to test this approach
and even implement it i and to
understand if by
targeting metabolism we can influence
the cartesian
effects of memory differentiation i
decided to move from academia
to industry and first to bluebird and
now to elevate fire
so we at elevate bio pursue a three
strong approach
focusing on innovation enabling
technology
and also building out the necessary
infrastructure
for the development of the next
generation balancing therapy
and we at elevate bio strongly believe
that the seahorse
technology is going to be very useful
for us
and helpful to achieve our goal as it
can be applied across multiple platforms
during the development of
cell-based therapies so not only in
research
to understand how manipulation of
metabolism can drive a desired phenotype
but also in cellular process development
to measure the effect of process or
process
change on t cell metabolism as well as
in corollary sciences to understand the
correlation between t cell phenotype and
response to immunotherapy as this is
essential for us to be able to develop
successful therapy
so unfortunately i'm not able to share
any internal data with you today
so i'm going to highlight data from the
literature
to support the idea that targeting
metabolism is a valid approach in the
development of cell-based therapy
melinfoss and colleagues published
really convincing data
showing that it's actually the intrinsic
properties of the car t-cells
turkeys out themselves that's the most
predictive factor
in determining clinical response
so what they did is they analyzed 41
samples
from patients with high risk cll that
had received at least
one infusion of cd19 targeted cut t
cells and they observed that
t cells isolated from
complete responders has high expression
of genes
driving memory particularly early memory
differentiation
whereas car t cells isolated from
non-responses
and have increased expression of genes
regulating glycolysis
as well as exhaustion
so based on this data since a more
memory-like phenotype seems to be
[Music]
responding or corresponding to
a positive clinical response how can we
use this information
and modify or engineer our
car t cells in such a way to drive
memory differentiation
so one approach would be to directly
focus on the co-stimulation
provided during the expansion process as
it was shown
that adoptive transfer of other t-cells
into mice
followed by priming that either ova
anti-cd27
or over on t41bb had very different
effects on
the cd8 t-cell memory versus effector
differentiation
cda t cells primed with 401 bb
produced lower amounts of the effects of
cytokines
perforin and ion2 in response
to re-challenge ex-vivo however despite
having a
lower effector response early on those
t cells were able to differentiate into
functional memory
as a higher frequency of them could be
detected in multiple tissues
including lung liver and spleen
57 days after the initial transfer
one possible mechanism how 41db albinism
[Music]
drives memory differentiation is by
increasing mitochondrial function
so as is shown here activation of
t-cells was anti-cd3 and
241 bb for 24 hours followed by
seven-day expansion and iso leads to an
increased mitochondrial content within
those t
cells as shown here by effects and
whereas
41 db organism or stimulation
does not affect the basal oxygen
consumption
it profoundly increases the respiratory
capacity of those cells
driving a metabolic femoral heart that's
associated with mammary tissue
in 2016 kajun and his team published
really really nice work showing that
the choice of co-simulation domain
within the car itself can have a
profound effect
on the metabolic phenotype of the
car key cell and therefore on the
cartesian function
so what they showed is that
inclusion of 411dd post stimulation
within the car design leads to an
increased
mitochondrial biogenesis
driving increased
oxygen consumption under basal
conditions
as well as increasing the mitochondrial
capacity
and overall and therefore leading to the
generation of t
cells with a central memory memory-like
phenotype and it's this
phenotype that's positively correlated
with clinical response
and i was actually really excited to see
that discoveries made in basic research
can be translated into a therapeutic
setting
so just to summarize what i've shown you
today i've shown you verbs describing
that
immune cells including b and t cells
have different metabolic requirements
for survival and function also
that effector and mammary t cell
differentiation
is regulated by metabolism-driven
processes
that clinical responses in cll
anyway are determined by intrinsic
programs of memory versus exhaustion
and finally that the choice of cool
stimulation can have a profound effect
on cardiac cell function
so i therefore strongly believe that
manipulating ketone metabolism
is a really promising approach to
generate t cells with immediate
anti-tumor function
but that can then also convert to
mammary t-cells
for a sustained immunity immediate
immune-mediated anti-tumor response
our knowledge has grown exponentially
within the last couple of years
however i think there's still quite a
few
things we need to understand for us to
be successful in implementing this
approach
and the design of cell therapy so these
are just a few obviously of the open
questions i'm curious to address
so we still need to understand what is
more efficient
in generating an effective and
persistent anti-tumor response
is it boosting oxidative phosphorylation
is it dampening
glycolysis or is it actually boosting
both of them but if we were to boost
both of them what would it do to a
pretty much juiced up t-cell at this
point
based on the central role cmic has in
driving metabolic reprogramming i think
it's also a really interesting
target to consider however
would the negative impact on
proliferation
outweigh the benefit of increased
objective metabolism and persistence
and what is the effect of feminic
deletion on feed cell functionality
would it affect cyberkind release
and i think another big area where we
really need to gain more understanding
is what is the influence on the cancer
biology
on the teeth biology so is it possible
to
override any type of tumor biology by
just armoring the car
t cell what do we have to consider
targeting the cancer at the same time
to get the optimal response
and then also do we have and most likely
match the modification to the tumor type
and what modifications would be more
efficient
so i finally last but not least
obviously would like to acknowledge the
people
that supported me throughout my
scientific endeavors and that's first
and foremost doug brain
who was a great mentor and actually
whose curiosity for science is
pretty infectious and then my colleagues
at bluebird
bio bear made the first foray into cell
therapy
and and obviously
my current colleagues at elevate bio who
share the same passion as i do for
targeting metabolism
in designing the next generation of
cell-based therapies
and lastly i would like to thank all of
you for taking the time to
listen to my seminar today so thank you
thank you so much sandra that was an
amazing
presentation we had lots of people are
watching and there's lots of
questions so uh we will now start the
question and answer portion of the
webinar
again if you have any question that
you'd like to ask please submit it now
we'll be able to get a couple of
questions in before the
end of the hour however even if we don't
make it to your question
we'll be forwarding all of them on to
sandra and the agilent team
to follow up with you additionally if
any of you would like to learn
more about the solutions that we offer
for cell analysis
you can follow the links on the bottom
left section of your screen
under the resource list to our new
immuno oncology and immunotherapy
webpages
let's get started
the first question sandra
is there currently any approved therapy
um or even maybe therapy and development
that you're aware of that includes
car plus a metabolic gene alteration
to promote cell persistence
so i know that there are some efforts
implementing those approaches but i have
to say i mean i
switched to industry about three or four
three years ago
and considering the strong support in
academia
i think industry is a bit slow to pick
it up i
i would have expected to see more by now
but yet
there are some efforts but they're all
pre-clinical and i don't know of
anything being already in the clinic
okay thank you we have a question here
relating to c mig the question is how
does c
make impact the potency of t cells
is there a balance that should be
achieved between
t cell fitness and t cell potency
oh i think this is a great question and
we always know that obviously
driving a persistent response is
essential to
have a successful immunotherapy-based
target
however you don't want to swing the
pendulum too much because you really
need the
potent anti-effector response
oh well not anti anti-tumor effects the
response early on
so to strike the right balance it's
actually going to be really hard i think
and it's something that
we have to be very cautious about that
we don't overdo it with the memory
because if we don't get
immediate tumor clearance early on then
it doesn't help us if we have memory
cells
so that's why we really need to think
about
how can we stimulate the details or
modify them or engineer them in a way to
maintain this plasticity
that gives us this really good punch
early on well then
also giving us the persistence and
i i obviously don't have the answer for
that and the data has to bear it out but
maybe we have to have a two-pronged
approach and if you want to
push them to really strong effects of
that one end
maybe there will never be a really good
memory so we have to then
think about do we go in with two
different populations to start off with
but it's a great question
great thank you very much sandra um
m talk torque is also asymmetrically
distributed in
effector and memory t cells um
do you think that that could be a link
to asymmetric activation of c
mic in these cells
oh absolutely so we obviously did verb
on
top so did jonathan powell so i just cut
it out
due to the you know time constraints
yes i think and talk is a very
attractive target
and one i would definitely pursue
so yes absolutely and it might actually
be easier to regulate and talk one level
than trying to modulate and hit the
sweep spot that's targeting mech
sandra maybe you could just thinking
about solid tumors in the tumor micro
environment
with a question here which is i suppose
asking your opinion about
um you know whether shaping car t cell
metabolism
you know how challenging that that will
be in solid tumors because of their
heterogeneity
i mean i i think that's a great question
and my general thoughts are
yes no i think definitely you can arm
the t-belt
in such a way to obviously make them at
least competitive because i think that's
a problem with the tumor they need the
same nutrients they
you know they drive very similar types
of metabolism but somehow
a tumor cell is always better which is a
shame
so i think so for this again
if you give the tumor cell time to adapt
i think you will
lose that rate every single time
so i think yes you have to um
on the cartier cell to be successful
early on
and yes i think you have to enable it to
successfully compete against it and i
mean that's really strong word by erica
he is showing that you know depending
on the glycolytic dependence of the
tumor that really affects your t cell
response
so yes so you have to target it and
again for this is what i try to get is
you also need to understand the tumor
biology so that you can kind of
um you know tailor your t
cell to the tumor you like to target
and maybe as i said you can hit the
tumor at the same time so that's the
nice thing about cellular therapy right
you take out the cells so you can
engineer them
and therefore you can maybe add drugs
that you know
inhibit glycolysis stop tumor growth and
then you can engineer t cells to be
resistant
to those drugs or you know to arm them
that they
now can compete better so i think
there's a lot of things you can do in
this area which is why i think it's
really exciting
so the possibilities are endless but to
identify with just once
the most successful one i think that's
the
challenge yeah i couldn't agree with you
more
um so regarding just comparing tumor
cells and immune cells
which in your experience are more
sensitive to amino acid deficiency
oh that's a good question and i actually
don't know i just think and again sorry
i
i'm just speculating female cells tend
to be
very adaptable to changing conditions
which is why they survive so well so i
think it's put under the same strain
that tumor cells would be able to
utilize other pathways better than t
cells do because for example lactate
they can cope with high lactate they can
take it out and use it for their
advantage whereas t
cells really don't don't do so well
in that environment so i actually think
having said that if you put strain on
and you know metabolic stress on cells
tumor cells will find a way around it
much better than t cells would
yeah there's a good question isn't it
maybe somebody in the audience will uh
will put that into the chat um
so the next question then so which of
which of these is
uh it's it's practical so
screening or isolation of less
glycolytic
cardi from a production or
pharmacological or genetic modulation of
metabolism
in car t cell design or propagation
so i think it's it's a two-pronged
two-stage process so yes you want to
have the cells i mean everyone talks
about now
more memory-like or less differentiated
so that they have this plasticity early
on
so i think so therefore to
you know either adopt your process so
that you tend to increase the percentage
of those cells during extension
or that you isolate those less
differentiated cells early on
i think that's one part of the puzzle i
think the other part you have to solve
is
once the t-cell encounters the tumor
i think you still need to modify the t
cell in such a way
to basically be immune i mean
but to resist this very stringent human
body from from
microenvironments so i think it's two
things we need to solve separately
thank you um coming back to metabolism
and you're obviously a huge uh
fan of of metabolism in you know in the
study of
metabolic parameters for immunotherapy
but do you
do you think that it's going to be a key
component for
immunotherapy success in solid tumors
and do you think the impact of that will
ultimately be higher than
for blood tumors
so yes so the answer is obviously yes on
the internet but
that's just as you said i'm a bit biased
so i'm not sure
it is for so let's go to solid tumors
i definitely think that you know
targeting metabolism
it is going to be important at
driving an effective immunity response
and
and i always like to think to take this
that's called the kitchen sink approach
throw in as much as you can to get the
best chances early on because you don't
want the tumor
to give the tumor time to adjust so you
want to give your back
big punch right away and i think so
therefore think yes metabolism is going
to be an essential component of this
however i still think yes it's not quite
the same stringency
sufficiency you have an esteem tumor so
you still have obviously
more nutrients available but i still
think that there's going to be some what
you learned
out of a solid tumor that can be
translated to hume tumors and then even
make the t-cell responses better against
them because
even indeed tumors right it's
interesting not every heme tumor
responds equally well
to cd19 card t-cells
so there's definitely a lot of
especially cll i think the response rate
is 20
so there's still a lot you can do to
increase the number of patients
benefiting from the therapy
and trying sandra just continuing on the
theme of kind of a broad view of
immunotherapy um can you take a few
minutes just to discuss
um you know the state of the field and
the direction
that you feel for for immunotherapy
where where it's going and
at what point you think it'll be truly
adopted for for clinical treatment
and what are some of the in your view
some of the major
gaps or major challenges ahead of us
oh that's a very broad question so
that's really interesting
um i can try to tackle it so
i think you see the potential right if
it works
it works phenomenally but
if it doesn't work we still don't always
understand why it doesn't work
so we really need to get a better
understanding of why it doesn't work
and then there's also you know
treatments out there or indication
so solid tumor we still haven't tackled
and then the biggest problem is also you
know
it's hard enough to find one
so one is the limitation of this local
response to it but then also to identify
those antigens
it's also obviously another challenge
and then you think about the tumor
heterogeneity
that needs to be addressed for a solid
tumor
so it's
it's a big question so i think the next
area is going to be solar tumor
to see this but it needs to be in
context
with um but
targeting the tumor heterogeneity so i
i don't think and again that's just my
opinion here
i don't think pastel castle therapy
can be a single modality in certain
settings so i think to think about how
to incorporate it into current
treatments
that's great but the potential i think
is really enormous
car i would say car but that would
obviously include also tcr therapy
and i think the next level is just like
to
to and that's what we think about right
at elevate
so yes the costs are really high right
now which are
prohibiting to make it widely available
but how about if you improve
manufacturing
candy drives down the codes if you move
away from you know
um like using viruses to produce the
cell can you do
in vivo editing and can you also
you know or think about an allo approach
so that you drive down the cost of the
product and i think this a lot of times
will then
actually make it more wildly applicable
and i think you also have to see so far
the other
thing is i think what would be a big
sticking point for those type of
therapies if it actually was
ending up to be a cure that would
obviously be such a game changer
compared to you know where a lot of
treatments right now are treating
achievements and they you know
will benefit the patients but the
relapse rate is really high and they are
not considered cured so
so this is where i i think that's my two
cents for that area
thank you sandra it was a very broad
question and you did a great job of
answering that
we're coming up to the uh the close of
the hour so
just a couple of uh and it's great that
we've had time for so many uh
questions and we have lots more actually
that we'll send on to you
um but a couple of uh smaller questions
just before we come up to the hour
um we talked about memory t cells and
that being you know one of the goals of
of your work what do you consider are
some of the best
markers for looking at memory t cells
yeah i mean it's not just memory right
you want the early memory so you want
tscm or tcm over tem right so just just
to even
um stratify there a bit so
i like and again i mean it's just a few
there's really nice panels out there
i think it depends on how far you want
to go but cd45 roll
cd45ra and ccs7 and if you want to
include
cd62l and cd95 actually give you a
really nice coverage of most of those
phenotypes
thank you just one last one then so
earlier in your talk you you talked
about aif
and the difference between t cells and b
cells but
um did you did you find that the
the aif knockout did you look at or
could you project
in terms of what effect i would have on
memory
no i mean unfortunately i didn't because
they have knockouts
they don't persist so if you were to
challenge them or in an inspection
i don't think they would they cannot
expand so they cannot go
through the effective phase so they
wouldn't form proper memory either
okay thank you um sandra
um thank you again for
an amazing presentation and as you did
as well i'd like to thank our excellent
audience and fantastic questions that
we've had today
so for everybody on the call until next
time thank you and
goodbye everyone
thank you for leading through this
discussion that was really
really really exciting thank you so much
thank you
you